O ne o
[Müzik]
bu Merhaba hoş geldiniz Ben Deniz Evet
bir yurtdışı üniversite danışmalıyım
mesleğim gereği son 15 yıldır lise son
sınıfta mezun oluyorum
ya sanki günlerde sürekli aynı gibi bu
yana karakterler gibi bende hep aynı
bölgede ama her seferinde bambaşka bir
heyecanla sürekli Gelecekten
olasılıklardan ve çokça ayarlardan
bahsediyorum işte bu karşılığa
bu oturan onyedi yaş
yapacağını nerede okuyacağım bunu
gelecekle ilgili ne gibi planlarını
beklediğini bana anlatırken içindeki
onyedi yaş dinliyor O günlerden çokça
gün almış gibi olarak biliyorum ki onu
bugünkü planları bugünkü giderleri
istemli veya istemsiz
O ne kadar çok değişikliği olmayacak Bu
planlanan hiçbir şey plana oynayacak
başka kesişmeler çıkacak karşısında ve
yol ayrımları tümden Kaderde olmaktan
bahsetmiyorum Ama hayatın içinde
şansın Kısmetin ve bazı kesişme nin hiç
de azımsanmayacak bir yeri olduğunu
söylüyorum Hatta çoğu zaman kontrolü
bizde olmadığını yani karşındaki onyedi
yaş anlatırken benzinde kocaman
birbirimize meyve dinliyorum ve onun
için çok heyecanlanıyorum bu Elif ne
istediğimi çok iyi bilmeyen ama önündeki
on senesini kıymetini planlama işkence
yaşamak yaşına sahip olmak istiyorum
hadi onu da farklı hislerinden ile ama
ne biçim seni verdiği bile
Sen benimsin önündeki en oluşan
karşılaşma babamın kızı olarak dünyaya
gelmek Aslında
konuşmamı konu başlığındaki çokça Evet
kısmı babam alt bana her ne yaparsan yap
çokça Emek ya vererek yapmayan olur
Bu Üstün de Anadolu'dan İstanbul'a
göçmüş tutacağım da oldukça dinler Bir
annenin evladı olarak Tıbbiye birinci
Bir Sebeple bir yarışma lan Büyük bir
risk alarak elindeki çok sınırlı
kaynaklara ilk Siz çekenlerin için 66
gibi hayal gerçekleştiren bir
hanımefendi ile tanışmayı gelmiş
hayatının çok ama çok zor önemli bir
piyano kazanmış ve kendini tıpatıp
benzeyen bir kız çocuğu sahibi olmuş O
da babamın kesişme diyor çok sert Benim
Babam
ve babasından öyle görmüştü Sabah evden
çok erken çıkar çok geç gelirdi çok ama
çok çalışacağım
ben sadece ona kadar Beklediğiniz Yemek
masasında oturduğumuzda böyle Nasılsın
yavrucuğum dediğini bekliyor balık Bugün
vatan için ne yaptım bugün milletin için
ne yaptın bugün kendin için ne yaptın
diye sorardı bize o zaman küçüklükten ve
Park kardeşim bu Üç bilinmeyenli denklem
sorusu karşısında yapmamız ağzımızda
o gözlerini büyüyerek bak artık yokum
suratına o biz acaba bebeklerde Biz
veremez bir zamanı gelmiştir
biliyorsunuz Bugün ben de aynı şeylerden
bahsediyorum
gençliğe bazı yurtdışı üniversiteleri
başvuru zorunluluğu olan topluma hizmet
etmeyi topluma geri dönmeyi bir fark
yarattı
bu Ey sevgili geçtik kafanı kaldırıp
Etrafına baktığında bir sürü fırsat
diyeceksin ama ancak bakarsan göreceksin
okursan öğreneceksin yaparak geçeceksin
şu Konfor alanından bir çık merak et
keşfet ise ise ise bu hakim atıyorum
Aynı babana söylemeye çalıştığı gibi
Fiat Doğan Bir gün eve yine saat onda
geldim
ben 16 yaşındayım bize 17'de bitiyor o
zaman
en
iyisi olduğu hizmet kuruluşunun bir
öğrenci değişim programı olduğunu ve
benim gideceğini söyledi [ __ ]
mı böyle bir çizgi film İngilizcesi
sınavındaki boşluk doldurma soruları
gibi size iki gün gelirdi sonra
gelirsiniz de tamamı isterdi enteresan
bir babanın enteresan fiziği Ben aslında
dım dım dım
Ne bulursam oku hiçbir şey bulamazsa
ketçap şişesi Arkasını oku Hissi içinde
ne olduğunu öğrenirsiniz diyerek
babasının sesini girebilme yönlendirdiği
kafasını Aşk romanlarından klasik lerden
kaldıramayan fiziği o sevdiğim
şekerlerden Türkçe eokul sürekli yazar
gündüz gözü Hayal yoruldu ama akademik
olan başka hiç bir şeyler yaptım yoktur
o yüzden bugün yaptığı meslekle Bazen
kendimi çok 200 hissediyorum çünkü
karşımdakine çalış çocuğun dersini
yükseltirken
Aslında de diyebiliyoruz en büyük Keşke
hayatta Daha çalışkan bir öğrenci
olmamış olmak Ben ettim sen etme
onyedi yaş işte yani her şey hediyesi
düşüne aslında bir halk bilmediğimiz
dünyaya öfkeliyiz öğretmenlerimizi
öfkeliyiz
ailemizi öfkeliyiz asilsiz isyankâr
palsi isyankâr ve
Türkçesi şımardın tekiyim bu Ama babam
Öğrenci Değişim sorduğu deyince benim
aklıma yabancı bir dili öğrenmek haklı
aileler yanında kalmak
he he kişisel değiştireceğim Yani tabii
ki yalan söylemeyeyim evden bir sene
uzakta olacak olmadan başlayacağız
birisiyle tamam
ne interneti arama motorlarının ne büyük
bir nimet olduğunu yeni neslin anlamında
pek emin değilim Halbuki ne kadar büyük
ve değerli bir şey bilginin parmağının
ucunda olması bir attan geçmiş olmalıyım
ki babam bir akşam odama geldi raftan
biraz sürede aldı A harfini açtı ve bana
değişik programında Avustralya'ya
gideceğini söylemişti burada öyle çıkışı
bu Avustralya hakkında altı köpeği de
bir resim bir paragraf 4 Pardon bir
resim bir paragraf 4 paragraf ve bir
tane Tamam at babaannesine parmağı koydu
ve dedi ki buraya gideceğiz
o resimde
ve Avustralya'nın kısmı Adası'nda
Yengeçlerin şifresine gücünde
sahilde
çekilmiştir ok uzun bir sahil
milyonlarca yengeç Bu çocuk bu
yengeçleri ellerine alıp olmayan bir iki
tane yerde çocuğun olduğu bir resim
bu yutturdu
içine bakıp Tamam dedim bu hayal etti
canlandırmanın için geçti
mı bu hayır de canlandırınız için biraz
açmak istiyorum iki buçukta yatmış 24
saat uçarak gittiğiniz yerden
bahsediyorum görüntülü konuşma yok Hayal
Ötesi bile değil o zaman
santral ve bağlanıyoruz sesiniz
karşınızdaki gecikmeli gidiyor herkesi
Avusturya ile karıştırdığı Bugün bile
kanguru dedim hayvanın adı olmak onu
atalım olan haricinde pek çoğunu
hakkında çok da bilmediği bir ülke
gidiyorum şu mutsuz bucaksız bir deniz
milyonlarca
yengeç geçti kendi nelere kendilerini
oyuncak yapmış
dişsiz çocukların Vatanına seni 1990
hayatımın dönüm noktası
sanırım orada yaşadığım olayların
tümüdür Ponpon alanından çıkıp ve o
uçağa bindiğin günden beri O seni yok
İşin ekmeğini yiyorum her anladık
düşünüyorum da öğrendiğimiz her şey
haricinde insanların içine bakıp gülüp
gözünün içine bakıp Günaydın demeyi
teşekkür etmeyi çocuklarıma geliştirir
şeklini ve hatta Şükrü ayrıştırmayı bile
orta öğrenimden Peki her şey güllük
gülistanlık mıydı Hayır Evet de hayır
dört tane farklı aile yanında kaldım
anlatayım ya hepsi birbirinden bir
enteresan the bir tanesini mesela
oruçtan kedisi vardı evin içinde
yaşıyorlardı o kediler bilimleri
eşyalarını kediler Ben böyle hırslandım
bekliyorum ki bir anne babası gelsin
Çünkü Hatice'm kedileri kapatsınlar yere
anne baba geldi dedim kediler eşyaların
kime diğer dediler ki niye eşyalarını
ortada bak
abone ol
daha sonra bu üyesi olduğu yani
Avustralya'da bir gönderdikleri hizmet
kuruluşunu üyeleri hafta sonları bizlere
bant değişim öğrencilerinin hepsinin
bunlar diye öyle hafta sonu bir yere
götürürler dediği hiç tanımadığım aile
aldı beni köfte yaşıyorum o zaman her
şehrinde götürdüler kuzeyine böyle bizim
Yayla dediğimiz gibi bir yere bir tahta
kulübe pul biberi elektriği yok
etrafında zaten hiçbir şey yok zıplaya
kavgalar başka hiçbir şey değil
Evin annesi dediki yer misin
O erkek de ben yoktu o zaman kim kim
yaptı katacağız gitti pankeki koydu Öyle
Bir Ok mu aldığım içimden dedim ki
yatılıda aynı kremi bir gidiyor ama
benim annem de bunu incecik yapar
Evet şimdi diyeceğim ki ki Ellerinize
sağlık Tadı da anne Kredi benziyor var
ama ayırmaya şimdi beni ama burada bu
kelimeyi kullanmak doğru mu çok elinde
ile krep ile de hak kelimesinin arasında
İngilizce'de çok küçük bir taraf var
ve ben
bu Ellerinize sağlık sonunda Ağrı Kredi
yazıyor diyeceğimiz evin
o da aynı nokta nokta yazıyor dedim
bir Düşünsenize kadıncağız başladı
olmaya o da ben Ne dediğimin farkında
değilim başladı ağlamaya bir tane
çeşitleri var o ağlıyor Bence elin
erkeğine olduğunu anlamış olmalı ki o da
kahkahalarla gülmeye başlıyor ve
ben kişisel yaşamını bu tip tamamlamış
daha sonra
iki ay olanlar çıkamadım hiçbir şey
yiyemiyorum
Ama Allah'tan Annem oğluma yeni
fotoğrafını koymuş
onlarla yaşadım sonra sonunda adamdan
çıkabildim mutfaktan su almaya gidiyorum
bir baktım ki bir koca tarantula böyle
yan yana geçtik
sonra birbirine bahçede oturuyoruz bir
bizim burada timsah dediğimiz orada
kertenkele diyorlar
kocaman bir yaratık
bu
kimsenin ortada yok öldürürüm öldürürüm
diye bağırıyorum Bizler Hayır öldüremez
yılanları yiyor dediğimiz yani ne anlamı
var
şu anki ne yaptığımızı keşif yolculuğu
daha mısınız arada ve ona farklı olana
saygı göstermeyen öğretti yani
hayallerindeki yurtdışı üniversiteleri
girmiş olan ama
yurtlarda ortak tuvalet kullanacakları
için o Yaygara koparan çocukların var ya
öğrencileri ardından çok biliyorum bekle
daha neler olacak evet de yaklaşık bir
sene sonra Geri döndüğümde bambaşka bir
insanın ve sanırım çıktığım Oo Dünyaya
bir daha da hiç geri dönemedim
ama o yani çocuklarla çalıştım çok
teşekkür insanlar böyle açın artıklarını
toprağa gömüyorlar pişirip yiyorlar Bana
da ikram ettiler Ben de yedim vallahi
çok güzel Aynı tadı tavuğa benziyor
O bizim zamanımızda diyeceğim sana yuvar
yaşadığını söylemeye evleniyor böyle
peynirli uzmanları büyük dışı
danışmanları
yaşantıları eğitim poşet hiçbir şey yok
ve o kadar bizsiz ki gelecekle ilgili
seçimlerimiz dört işlemi zorla yapan
benim üniversite tercihlerinde ilk
sırada e kılınır
ya bir arkadaşım okuyorum konuda bir
bölümü o zaman daha şuradan geri döndüm
bunu pek iyi değiliz yine evde
uzaklaşmanın yollarını arıyorum Son Gece
Son tercih
yazdığım ve beslenmede çok ederek
bitirdiği turizm otel işletmeciliği nin
ilk sene dersinde Mahmut ekonomi bunu
bir Excel birleşik
özellikle Turizm sektöründe
basamakları alttan çıkarsınız yavaş
yavaş öyle sahada ne olduğunu bilmeden
ofisiniz olmaz Bush bu Bize öğretilen
bölüm dersleri arasında yoktu o yüzden
1996 yaşında mezun olduğunda
Sultanahmet'te o zaman açılmakta olan
ultra lüks otelde görüşmeye giderken
bana verecekleri ofisin manzarası
düşünüyordum görüşmeden Konya olmayı
kabul ederek çıktım
ve
Otelcilik nasıl bir şey dedin
vermelisiniz Bu başaşağı sadece içinden
bilmezsiniz
bırakıp böyle yan tarafta küçükler bir
kapıdır ışığı ile aydınlatılmış uzun
koridordan uzun uzun yürürsünüz yukarıda
misafirlerinize ıspanak yatağında bir
soktu tercih ederseniz aşağıda bugün
tavuklukta değişim verme çıkar Aslında
sohbetlerini sabredebilirim de
sabredebilirim de bu büyük etkenlerinden
bir tanesi hayatta Ama sabah saat beşte
kalkıp da al sultanahmet'i gidip
kahvaltıya kapı açmak Bu prenses kızına
çok ağır geldi annesinin aradı dedi ki
annesi far
daha sonra kaldık uluslararası havayolu
şirketi ile görüşmeye gitti böyle bir
dünya haritası konular
Bu sadece kıtalar var bir ülke sınırları
yok yanında da 30 tane şehir ismi benden
beklenen bu şehirlere bu harita
yerleştirilen hayatımda hiç bu kadar Bu
tabloyu bilmiyorum yapışıyor şu an
Ziyaret ettiğim Başkentin ile harika
doğru yeşertilir emin değilim Ağla
çıkmıyorsun bir daha aramazlar diye
başka görüşmek başka yerlerde görüşmeye
gidiyorum Bir yandan da deliler gibi
Atlas çalışıyorum Bu sayede Çok üst
düzeyde binlerce öğrenmesi bilgisine
sahip olduğum ve yollar mısınız 30
şehirden hemen hemen hepsinde gittim
gördüm gezdim bugün hiçbirisi o işi
yanlış oldu çok daha büyük beklentilere
çok vakit kaybetmeden O günkü sayılır
hiç şirketlerinden bir tanesi işe girdik
bir yemek yaşadı programı çekiyorlar Ben
de WhatsApp'ta stüdyoda set arkasında
okuyup geceleri doğruyorum
var ama bir kendime yediremiyorum Bu
arada havayolu şirketinden iki Görüşmeye
çağırdılar artık nasıl işaretleri sen
bilmiyorum ama otomasyondan gidemedim
şimdi diyorum şimdi istedim Bu yol
nereye doğru olacaktı Sonra sebzelerle
de olmadığı inandım aradım sakin dedim
yok babam
bir kahve içiyorsun hiç bizim hiç hayatı
boyunca böyle eş-dost hatır işlerine
sıcak bakmaz Hadi ki Otel müdürü olan
hastalarından biri ne Bizim kız da
Turizm okudu teyze Bir de hayatın
kurtulacak ama deneyeceğim
gidemedi benim kariyer anlamında ki tek
yapılanlar pazar günleri gazete ile
beraber verilen insan kaynakları eki ama
o kadar Bunu hala Hipo kocaman
ilanlarını bakıyorum yanında
bir yandan da babamın İdare etmeye
çalışıyorum çünkü bir sene olmuş Biz
burada da hala aramışım Ve babam PC
ifade homurdanıyor kaçlı kestim
küçük olarak
Ve
Ofis giden ve bu işi bağlantılar için
bir kızcağız var Türkiye işleri için
de ofise de televizyonu açıp akşama
kadar Bangır Bangır arabesk dinleyerek
kemik yaratıcı ıslatıyoruz Şimdi bunu
yapıyorum ama hiçbir şekilde kazandım
yetmiyor babamdan diyemiyorum o
söylediler kişinin arka sokaklarını bir
tane böyle bu küçük bir Türk
Üniversitesi açılmış ders verecek Hoca
alıyorlar Bendeki gidelim akşam dersi
veriyorum hiç bize de etkili ederim
gittim oraya dersler daha başlamadı
Derya öğrenci işleri ofisinde çalışır
başladım çalışmaya
beraber bir emekli eğitim setiyle
Çalışıyorum Aynı zamanda bu yeni
üniversitenin Kağıt işlemi ha geliyoruz
ona çok güzel çalışıyoruz ama bugün bunu
Aramızda bir husumet var Bu nedense
böyle fikrimi
söylüyorum o şimdi bu yüzden hiç beraber
kutuları bu kadar çalıştığımız bir gün
gittim ben Müdür anlamını odasına geri
geldim dedi ve eşyaları toplamaya
başladım müfettişleri ki Ne yapıyorsun
sen farklı mavi dedim dayanamıyorum
merak eden Dur bir dakika dur bir dakika
dedi telefon aldı takdirini aradı falan
canım bağlantı telefona dedi ki sana bir
kız gönderiyorum Sakın bir kızı kaçırma
Selam Bugün bile aklıma geldikçe hala
aynı heyecanı Ellerim titrer falanca
hanımla görüştüm o zamanın Muazzam
direktörü ile görüştüm Annem bizi ya da
okuldan sonra bir türlü opampin al
kapısı veya okul olmuş orası Bu arabanın
içinde oturmuş Biraz önce ne olduğuna
inanarak bir şey anlamadım Sevinç
çığlıkları içinde
seni 1998 hem dolarla maaş alacağım hem
de hayatımı değiştirecek işi almışım ama
hepimiz haberim yoktu
o nerede okuduğum bölümü Sen ne yaptın
bugün yaptığım isek o zaman ki hayalleri
idealleri nerede
O ne oldu da ben bu işe başladım
bilmiyor
var
1998'de öğrenmiş ne ofisine başladığınız
eğitim kurumunda bir süre çocuklardan
dolayı ara vermiş olsam da yurtdışı
danışmanı olarak geri döndüm 12 yıl
boyunca koşa koşa
sevinçle mutlulukla aynı eğitim
programına gittim
2019 senesinde yönetimsel bir takım
değişiklikler oldu orada bizim tipimiz
anneni Arama zamanı geldi mi senin
aradım Dedim ki anneye
ediyorum no yaşıyor
bu olmadı aslında istifa mi ona
yapılışını arasında hem kısa bir iş hem
de pandemi diye bir şey var bu Karanfil
süresince İstanbul'da betona baka baka
Ege'ye taşınmaya karar vermiş bir göç
kafilesini niye diye şaka bir yana da
yıllardır önemli saygıyla eğildiği Türk
eğitim Derneği'nin Tamda hayallerindeki
gibi bir kasabada bir okulunun olduğunu
de ben hazır olduğunda bu okulun
yurtdışı üniversite danışmanı arıyor
olduğu bir his işinizi midir
Düşünsenize Ben resmen önce Hazır
olsaydın birlikte İkisi de sonra hazır
olsaydım bir pozisyon olmayacaktı bekle
yani karşımda otururken bu onyedi yaş
anlatırken on senin planlarını
ve
astral ya gönderdiği yaşlıyım aşağı
yukarı bir daha belirtir edebilirdi
bilmiyorum ama Hayatımın tek bir günü
bile değiştirmek ister bu muhteşem
insanlarla tanıştım muhteşem kesişmeleri
olduğu Hayır oldu şer olduğu Kimisi
temiz olduğu Kimisi ders oldu bu arada
Baba Evet yoldu
Ama bunlar oldu pamuk gibi bir adam ol
bir başarı hikayesi anlatamadım Kusura
bakmayın Ben düştüm kalktım ya doğru
sandığı yanıldım epeyce Nisa oldum Ama
hayatta her günün Mutlu geçti da
çokça İnekler çok çok hayalet Gerisini
de havale et bugünkü mesajı size bu
Teşekkür ederim Hayat bir şey
söyleyeceğim Baba